Keezy started as an experiment.
We wasted many, many hours just playing with it.
I would say more hours playing with it than making it.
We like saying it's for kids of all ages and we mean like, 30-year-old kids, too.
We created a music toy called Keezy.
It's an app that has eight colored tiles.
You can record any sound you want into it and play those sounds back.
You really just have an instrument in your hand, which is so cool.
We made an instrument.
Yeah, it's really fun showing off Keezy at parties.
Seeing people who are normally awkward around music play with it...
...and really feel like they're making music.
My partners and I got to do so much to not only just building the interface...
...but working on all the marketing stuff, directing the live-action commercials,...
...so working with Reggie Watts was really awesome.
So Death by South West was around the corner.
We really wanted to build a giant Keezy with freakin' huge tiles.
Yeah, to see a really fun, popular thing that,...
...like, some of our favorite musicians are using and having a lot of fun with...
...to then becoming this giant centerpiece in an installation...
...is such a crazy thing to see happen to something as humble as a phone app...
...with eight squares on it.